hello folks welcome to rational science
another day another night
and today we're going to be dealing with
space
what the hell is space
everybody wants to know
anyways uh let's begin first with uh
some of the headlines in the news
and apparently the ukraine war is over
because uh they went back to covet
this is one of the headlines you'll see
out there in the news looks like this
okay it says a new wave of covet 19 is
coming here's how to prepare
so we
it looks like uh kobet is making a
comeback at least in the news i don't
know
if out there you know i don't know if
i'm gonna have to get a third vaccine
now you know to travel but yeah they're
saying you got to prepare they're
already coaching you on this
which means i guess that uh
the ukraine war is no longer
news or there's very little news it's
just become routine now you know more
sanctions and
more bombings killing people you know
the usual no no biggie
uh but as a result of the ukraine war
you know um
a lot of companies from the united
states especially you know they pulled
out of russia
you know they have starbucks and apple
youtube facebook
mcdonald's you know all of these pulled
out of uh
russia you know they they were
instructed to or coached or
uh suggested that they uh
suggested that they pull out
and so yesterday you know i went to
moscow okay i went to moscow
to find out you know what kind of
changes there are in the country now
that all these companies are pulling out
and yeah i verified exactly that you
know um for example i went to see a
mcdonald's
and everything's changed now you know
it's no longer
you know the golden arches
the this this is what you get if you
travel to russia now this is what you're
going to be seeing okay
uh that's the new sign that the russians
have for mcdonald's now that mcdonald's
has pulled out
so yeah and you might even get some um
bear meat instead of you know uh regular
cow meat so just be aware of that okay
yeah so uh all this is out of the news
now uh we're really back to covet and uh
one fellow said over there that uh maybe
just maybe you know this conducive to
world war three
and it is a possibility
and remember this is something new in
the world you know this is not like
alexander the great encroaching on the
persian empire or anything like that or
the romans on the greeks or
egyptians and so on
no this is a little different because
now you have
you could say three empires on earth
okay
and that's the united states empire the
chinese empire and the russian empire
and now one's encroaching on the other's
um territory
and that could create some big problems
for all of us okay
so do not be surprised if um the end of
the world comes a little sooner than you
expected okay
sleep with one eye open that's my
suggestion
anyways a foul says says the slowing of
population growth has been by choice and
through some self-destructive
self-destruct mechanism people can
easily have more children if they stop
using birth
control uh
yeah i don't think so you know i think
what's happened here is that uh you can
see that
um the birth rates
across this is the whole planet okay
what you're seeing here this is the
world population growth rate
has gone down in every country in the
world essentially
you know in the last uh 50 years at
least
and it's not only gone down it's gone
steadily down slowly but surely going
down
uh last time it was uh in 1963 was the
highest last highest level which was uh
2.1
growth rate and that's been dropping
steadily until we have now around one
and if things continue as they are by
mid-century we're going to reach zero
population growth
and you say well why is that so what's
happening
well
what's happening is what is known as
transition
people moving from the country to the
cities
big corporations are taking over the
farms they're producing uh you know with
economies of scale so that they can
produce food for
people around the world make some money
and they're pushing the little farmers
out into the city
when the families come into the cities
they have a different lifestyle no
longer the lifestyle in the country you
have the first issue is culture another
one is economics you know money
uh jobs
and um
and then you know uh yeah again the
culture changes and and women
not only women but men as well they
don't want to have children anymore you
know besides the fact that you can't
keep ten children in an apartment
uh in in the farms they used to have ten
children you know who was it there was
this fellow his name was
uh jacob also known as israel
and he had 12 boys one girl at least
right
13 kids
and everybody wanted to build empires
you know in those days uh 2 000
a little more in the case of jacob uh
but today
um you know today no one wants to build
empires you know you
you give thanks to god if you make it to
the end of the month
so no uh there's no purpose of uh for
having children that's the issue and a
lot of that has to do again with the
transition going from uh
you could say from farmers to urbanites
okay we're all becoming urbanized people
we're all concentrating in the cities
just like you know when you put a little
piece of bread
and you leave it for several days all
the bacteria go in there and
and turn it green
and population starts expanding
and at some point it overturns
population pyramid overturns and all
those bacteria go down until extinction
because there's no more bread underneath
them to take advantage of and that
happens to every species essentially
okay
okay follow brings up an issue about
neanderthals is built unaware of
neanderthal and denisovan dna found in a
significant percentage of the world's
populations
is that so we found denisovan
blood in
in uh people around the world humans
it's well established that there was
inner breeding
established by whom
what do you mean well established you
mean you believe it
you know so what is this well
established who established it and who
believed it
i mean was this the pope who established
that as a law and says
there was breeding
so help me god
[Laughter]
nanda those didn't die out they just
blended in
yeah that's the
uh theory that is going out on out there
um you know i don't know if you want to
believe that nonsense
and the reason they put the
interbreeding the what is known as
admixture theory out there is because
they had no solution to how the
neanderthals disappeared they don't know
how the woolies disappeared willie
mammoth did they disappear because they
interbred with humans as well
you know uh how about the dodo bird did
it disappear because it had sex with
humans as well
i mean where did you get this inner
breeding this admixture theory
okay
and uh so here uh here we put it in the
right perspective okay
okay this is fonte pablo he's a
geneticist
and what is a geneticist well geneticist
is a paleontologist who concludes that
interbreeding between two distinct
species causes extinction of one of them
based on what molecular account
he's a bean counter that's all he is
then he extrapolates
this bean counting
and says oh i can tell you how the
neanderthals disappeared
okay how did they disappear well here we
have two percent
of
um
neanderthal dna in us
and so that proves
you know that the neanderthals and us
enter bread and so how did they
disappear well they were smaller
population and they essentially
dissolved in our much bigger population
supposedly a ten to one ratio with
respect to the neanderthals and so we
kind of absorbed them in okay
and so yeah these bean counters they say
look we can tell you how neanderthal
disappeared
and the reason they concluded this they
had no
solution
to enter to the disappearance of the
neanderthals okay
and so here um
here we put in the right context okay
here's a little picture that says it all
this is how
um
the denisovans and uh the
met
or greeted the neanderthals when they
approach their caves over there in
russia in the middle of russia okay here
it is this is how they greeted each
other you know
uh
they had a lot of fun together they
swapped wives right it was all friendly
they drank beer is that what you're
saying happened
you know i i think not
i think what's happened here is that uh
you know the um
the neanderthals and the denisovans were
two different species
and that essentially is what uh what you
see in the in the genes that's what
comes out of the these studies to say
that
they they mixed
it's like saying that a lion and the
tiger me meet and have fun in the middle
of the
jungle you know or in the plains or
wherever do you think if you set a a
real life tiger you know one from the
wild and you
sick them or
well you just introduce them into lion
territory or vice versa what do you
think would happen would they have sex
or would they try to kill each other
and so what's different between
neanderthals and denisovans what's
different between humans and
neanderthals
what's different between humans and
humans
i mean
just now i finished saying that russians
are are killing ukrainians and if there
were americans there they would kill
them too and vice versa
this is humans and humans are we
friendly to each other well we're a
little more civilized today so we do
have you know intermingling between
races and countries and whatever
but uh in the wild out there
the first rule is you don't trust anyone
and if you don't understand that well
maybe you should go to the wild and you
know sleep with a lion see if they trust
you
or any animal out there you know
chimpanzees uh elephants just go and
live with them you know
what was it the
dances were wolves yeah go ahead dance
with wolves see see if they accept you
in their group and they're in their pack
no
all these species killed each other
and not not even between species within
species they killed each other the worst
enemy of a neanderthal was another
neanderthal one clan killed the other
clan if they could
and you see that with chimps today you
know when one
troop goes and kills the other troop
takes all the girls you know they're not
so stupid
yeah the young girls
we want those you know
uh so here's uh pabo swante pabo's his
uh this is from his original paper the
one that made him favors in 2010
and there's a little bit of history
behind it i can't go through all of it
today but all i can tell you is by 2007
uh he was named
as one of the most
influential or 100 most influential
people
uh on earth
by time magazine that he was going to
become a very influential person why
because he was in charge of the genome
project
at the max plaque institute in which
they were going to decide who is right
did neanderthals disappear because
humans
mated with them or killed them or
because of climate change or something
like that
and they had to you know they had
already pretty much ruled out climate
change they had ruled out that humans
killed them a lot of people still
believe that but no they had they
there was a big push to prove at all
costs
that humans mated
you know with neanderthals and that had
something to do with our disapp with
their disappearance and why we still why
we have some amount of dna from the
neanderthals in our blood today
the problem is we haven't found any
mitochondrial dna in our blood we
haven't found any y chromosomes in our
blood from neanderthals we just found
two percent commonality
with dna from the neanderthals and that
could just as well be attributed as many
alleged out there in theory eyes
that we had a common ancestor and it is
probably the the reason we only have two
percent today but see the the inner
breeding crowd
they want to prove at all costs that it
was interbreeding
that killed the neanderthals because
they got their names in light that's the
only reason and here's monte paulo's
paper okay here it is
these are a couple things that i pulled
out of there so that you can analyze for
yourselves you can look up this paper
okay there it is at the bottom a
striking observation is that
neanderthals are as closely related to
what to a chinese and a background
individual as to a french individual
even though morphologically recognizable
neanderthals exist only in the fossil
record of europe and western asia
so how did the pop ones little island
the middle of nowhere right
uh how did they
get neanderthal blood in them
and then
he continues on that same paper so the
analysis of the neanderthal genome shows
that they are likely to have had a role
in the genetic ancestry of present-day
human outside of africa
outside of africa see they always put
africa against the rest of the world
when they talk about neanderthal they do
not introduce papuans and they do not
introduce another group which is the
american indians which also have
more according to the studies right more
neanderthal dna than europeans
then europeans the europeans you know
the guys who slept with the neanderthals
they have less neanderthal dna than the
american indians and the pop ones
okay i hope that
you know uh lightens a bulb in your head
okay
it says although this role was
relatively minor
this is in their paper okay given that
only a few percent of the genomes of
present-day people outside of africa are
derived from neanderthals
in other words he says it's it's a very
tiny amount
in fact the paper said anywhere between
two to three percent
and so that tiny amount they said well
because of this we conclude that there
was some mating but it was very minimal
did that cause the extinction of the
neanderthals the fact that we have two
to three percent neanderthal blood
meaning that the lion and the tiger made
it out there in the jungle in the caves
it had sex between these two species
kind of hard to believe but here we have
uh another couple
testimonies from mr pablo okay he's the
head honcho on all this stuff right and
this is what he says in a couple in
subsequent papers and talks that he gave
okay here it is if there was a
contribution from neanderthals to
europeans we would expect europeans to
share more genetic variants with
neanderthals than what africans uh do
since there's never been neanderthals in
africa okay that was his working
hypothesis okay
but then he says in another day he says
had there been contribution from
neanderthals i would have expected it to
be in europe and nowhere else
okay
because neanderthals lived in europe and
western eurasia but we found it also in
china and even papua new guinea where
everyone is sure there had never been
neanderthals
okay so what should we conclude
that broke his hypothesis that you know
non-africans
are
have more
neanderthal blood and africans okay
great so he proved that how about these
guys how about the pap ones how about
the chinese how about the american
indians
how did they get infected
and so yeah i mean that breaks this
hypothesis but they never emphasize
that negative part because they already
got their nobel prize you know they're
already in the news they already got
their prizes everybody believes they're
uh great because they discovered that
neanderthal disappeared because of
interbreeding nobody's going to remember
that ever again this paper the fact that
it was wishy-washy they just take it as
as a given and now you have people out
there trying to figure out how much
neanderthal blood they have in
themselves
and i always say hey i can tell you
right now without you having to have a
dna test
you have at least 50 dna blood in you
neanderthal dna blood in you and it all
comes from your mother
i mean if you believe in this nonsense
uh you you really got a problem okay
okay another fellow says uh mankind as
we know it will go extinct okay the
earth has a finite lifespan yeah the
earth might but we're not gonna wait for
the earth to go extinct i'm sure we're
going to go extinct a little sooner than
the earth goes extinct okay so the
extinction of the earth is not going to
cause the extinction of man man is going
to become extinct for some other reason
that has very little to do with the
extinction of the planet earth or the
environment or whatever okay if
humankind is to survive beyond
terrestrial life a new form of human
will need to be engineered or
re-engineered right to survive
interstellar travel
what we understand as human or mankind
will no longer exist well he's he's
right about that if if we had to create
um
android robots
cyborgs whatever you want okay we
created these
uh frankensteins right
they would not be us
okay so that means that even if these
fellows would travel outside of the
earth and go to another planet and
whatever make more robots or copies of
themselves that would not be us we're
gone okay so that's the first issue but
then the other issue is
this fellow thinks that somehow you know
maybe he watches too much star trek he
believes that maybe we've got a chance
any chance whatsoever of ever making it
to the nearest star not the farthest
star the nearest star
you know the alpha centauri system out
there
maybe uh 4.3 light years away meaning
that round trip would be like nine like
nine
years traveling at the speed of light
we're never gonna go to the nearest star
we die here in this so-called solar
system this is our
world this is our
country this is our land this is where
we put the flags right
and uh
i don't think we're even gonna conquer
uh colonize
mars or the moon
no reason to
they might send an expedition maybe to
the moon i doubt it but let's assume you
know they send an expedition there to
mine the moon because they find some
minerals that could be useful here on
earth they would be very expensive
to send missions out there to mine to
take all the equipment necessary to mine
on the moon here you know just one light
second away right
i mean the moon is wet uh 400 000
kilometers away
and traveling at the speed of light at
300 000 kilometers per second we would
arrive in a little more than a second a
second and a half assuming we could
travel at the speed of light of course
we're very very far away from that but
let's just assume we go to the moon
and to take all the equipment necessary
to mine on the moon okay
that would be a monster
just that alone
but even if we did that then we have to
mine it
bring it back to earth
it's just a trip going back and forth i
mean it's going to be very extremely
expensive what are you going to mine
iron
okay so you get your
uh uranium okay
or some
uh you know
less
uh popular element here on earth okay so
you go to the moon you bring the stuff
back how much is that going to cost you
is it going to be cost effective
and please don't try it with mars okay
it's out of range
okay another follow suggests something
else let's see if we can avoid
extinction here it is would it be
possible to clone extincted extinct uh
how many
uh hominin i guess species or use
genetic engineering to make the gene
pool larger
okay so we make these uh little babies
we inject some new
dna in them maybe some from some
neanderthal that we were able to
duplicate their
their genes or whatever right we
duplicate them we make a clone of a
neanderthal now we inject some of that
dna into a
human population uh maybe women who
want to try it it could be you know so
they donate their babies okay inject him
see if we can get some variation
in our uh gene pool okay
or just evolve from cyborgs into
full mechanical androids with synthetic
biology and let a super intelligent ai
control everything to make sure there
will be no extinction
man these guys do watch a lot of star
trek don't they a lot of matrix i mean i
think they should get their feedback on
the ground and just
you know open up the books or or
whatever and you know
learn some of what the reality is these
people are living on cloud nine i mean
at least that's a plan of the
technocrats and transhumanists yeah and
i believe that that's the case with
transhumanists you know these
people believe that uh
we're about to hit the singularity and
take off
uh we're gonna be inventing
things exponentially
what things do we need
what things can the
robots the computers whoever you want
the cyborgs
androids super intelligence whatever you
want
what things can they invent that we
don't already have and that we
actually need
what can you
imagine i mean if if you're gonna have a
hard time imagining what new inventions
are up ahead
uh the
robots are not gonna do much better
believe me to think that they have some
super intelligence and that they're
going to create some stuff that we
actually need here among humans
you know it's just nonsense a pure
absolute nonsense you don't have your
feet on the ground anymore
and so yeah to think that we're going to
be building kids maybe at the factory
you know
on a conveyor belt and
sending them out i mean why do we need
kids
if if
if we
if you think we need kids why don't you
put a factory
that produces children
i mean i think that's a good i mean if
there's a great demand out there i would
do it you know produce kids
in the factory maybe have women put them
out and maybe you build them with a
little bit of android stuff or cyborg
stuff you know
kind of like
frankenstein you know or whatever even
just leave them as they are just have
women produce children
and you feed them to the world
is there such a demand for children out
there
does anybody want children
you know i would think there's the other
way around people don't want children
especially if they're into cities they
don't need a factory to produce them
they can produce them themselves
and nobody's doing it and the question
is why not
okay and i'll tell you why not because
they moved to the city you have this
urbanization what is known as transition
from the country to the city and here's
a
a graph that i showed the other day it
gives you puts it in the right
perspective okay here it is this is the
urbanization of the world this is the
entire planet here you see
several countries but then the red line
is the world and the red line is wet
we're all becoming urbanized we're all
moving to the cities or more and more
the country is being left to the big
corporations and the big corporations
i don't know of anyone any corporation
out there producing children you would
think that if it's such a big business
people would get into the into the
market right
and no i don't i don't think this is
gonna happen okay so
we're not producing children because we
are the last humans the last generation
of humans on the planet okay
uh
it dies here in
in a very short while whatever that
means to you it could be a question of
months
if ukraine and uh russia lead to world
war iii it could be
this year for all we know i mean can't
sleep with one eye open you know
uh could be happening a few years could
happen in maybe a couple decades you
know i can't tell you when it's going to
happen i'm just saying you know we're
very close to extinction we're very
close to extinction because again we
have
on the one hand we have the three
empires
collapsing and colliding against each
other they're kind of encroaching on
each other's territory the united states
cannot grow as fast as china right now
and china's catching up in its economics
and united states doesn't like that and
so maybe you know that's one of the
reason we do have a war in ukraine now
and maybe all this was planned in
advance
to stop china from growing and
we just got to see where this leads but
believe me you know we got a problem
because
right now this is the entire planet it's
no longer you know a little group of
people called the greeks you know
with alexander you know running after
the persians
that was just local
and there were we had all this stuff
throughout history today we're at the
top of the world where
anything that we do affects the entire
planet
so we're in a different situation today
this is no longer history repeats itself
and the united states goes down china
arises above it
it's not going to happen
it's not going to happen the united
states is not going to allow china to
surpass it and maybe that's part of the
reason we have a ukraine war today
so uh
again sleep with one eye open that's all
i can recommend to you
okay folks i had a fellow who
criticized my
science series and i'm addressing some
of the issues he raised okay
one by one and i addressed a couple of
them already today i'm going to be
addressing
a third segment here something this
fellow said
so let's just
roll on see what this fellow had to say
give me a second here so that i can
turn this on here it goes listen
carefully
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal are
is science an ongoing process
is the problem in science today that the
mathematicians don't yet have all the
answers
you know the wording there is quite
important it says we don't know the
complete answers to these questions and
that is why science is an ongoing
process because yeah we have some of the
answers but we don't have all of the
answers
okay i'll address first the second part
okay
whether we have all the answers okay and
that will lead probably to a reply uh an
answer to the first one which is
uh you know whether uh
um
you know um what was it uh
uh
i can't remember what that first one was
anymore okay anyways the the issue is
you know whether um
we have any answers today
and the answer i can give you is that we
have no answers today from the
mathematical establishment
okay what kind of answers are people
looking for or some of the answers that
people are looking for that have not
been addressed in 2 500 years at least
since the days of the greeks
and here are
just a rundown on that so that you can
see what i'm talking about okay
we have not a single answer uh do we
know what gravity is
what causes gravity
you know here i always do my famous
experiment okay and get the pencil here
we let go with a pencil
and it falls down
and you see nothing here and you see
nothing here you touch nothing here
nothing here other than there right
which is not meant to be a cause of of
gravity okay so we let go of the pencil
and falls to the ground
nobody can tell you what causes that to
happen
two thousand five hundred years no one
can tell you what causes that to go down
and i addressed that the other day you
know uh this all thinks that space time
and the first thing there is that you
know space-time works out there
space-time in other words the
general relativity theory which is not a
theory it's just a mathematical
description has to do with giant masses
it doesn't have to do with warp space be
you know space being warped down here at
this level
a lot of people don't understand that
okay that's one issue but here uh what
is the explanation well here it is okay
uh this is from brian green okay this is
so you can look it up okay it's not not
me putting this uh you know raising
straw man or whatever here it is
this is this is the mechanism why the
moon doesn't fly out of the solar system
why it doesn't fly out of the earth
orbit
okay so uh
[Music]
is this the mechanism we're saying
there's a warped canvas there
meaning warp time because that's what
that canvas is those lines there they
represent time
one of those okay one of those lines so
we have warped time and here's the
mechanism they propose i've shown this
the other day okay
is that what we have we have warp time
is that what's preventing the moon from
flying out or the earth from flying out
of the solar system
a curved wall of time
it's the roulette mechanism
and so this is what we have today and
what can you say are are you going to
believe that this is
what causes gravity so this is an
irrationality mainly because they're
doing it with concepts this is not a
physical description or or even
mechanism explanation for why the earth
or the moon don't fly out of the solar
system or for that matter any other
planets asteroids and whatever why do
why do they all revolve around the sun
what keeps them there what is the
centripetal
force that you know pulls them
towards the sun while the thing is
trying to
you know orbit and get out of the
sun's orbit okay
so this is the issue the issue is that
they have no explanation for gravity how
about magnetism i covered that the other
day as well you can look it up in more
detail than today okay and here you have
a magnet and it's uh in the water and
you can see that the magnet is pulling
one
iron filing at a time towards it
so in that region called the field
magnetic field
uh as mr um
faraday and and mr james maxwell both
said you know that in that region you
have matter in motion they cannot
conceive
of you know that region being without
some kind of exotic matter
and there's something in motion in there
so because you can see it's pulling one
magnet at one iron filing at a time
so how do you explain this and you know
again what they say is that
the
the that the um what is it the domains
are aligned that's what they that's one
of the answers they give you domains are
aligned as i discussed the other day the
other one that they say is that the
electrons are spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise
so what so they're spinning clockwise
counterclockwise the domains are aligned
how does that in any way
shape or form
uh
pull on one of those iron filings right
through the water towards the skin of
the magnet that's what you got to
explain so we have no explanation for
magnetism
and
none for gravity how about electricity
are we doing any better with electricity
does anybody on planet except us here
understand how electricity works okay
let's find out here this is electricity
according to the establishment here you
see it okay you have a circuit on the
left okay and they say it's the rolling
of beads from atom to atom
and there you see it on the upper right
the big atom blue blues are the atoms
the
uh red ones are the electron beads and
what we're doing here is simulating with
hydrogen atoms essentially and what
they're saying is that
what electricity is simply the flow of
electron beads from atom to atom
and that's essentially the
model also used by
albert einstein essentially you know
to explain the photoelectric effect that
he said there's these
charges and
that are being hit by photons during the
photoelectric effect and that's what
electricity is
so everybody agrees that this is what
electricity is this is how
the electric universe also explains
electricity the flow of charges as they
call it
and the problem with all this is that
atom on the bottom right
if you are going to explain
uh ionization if you're going to explain
quantum jump if you're going to explain
electricity you're using that planetary
atom that you see on the bottom right
okay and so the only issue there that
the person has to explain is why doesn't
the electron bead fall to the nucleus
which was what
actually you know triggered the
investigation of the atom at the
beginning of the 20th century people
wanted to know why doesn't the electron
fall
to the nucleus
and to this day we have no explanation
for that and i'll add another one and
that is why doesn't the electron fly out
of the atom spontaneously
what keeps it bound to the proton or the
nucleus or whatever
so this is the issue we have no
explanation for the atom and if you
don't have an explanation for the atom
meaning you don't have an atom to
explain electricity then you don't have
electricity you do not understand
electricity it's just as simple as that
okay so uh
uh you know we have no understand
mathematicians don't have any
understanding of electricity how about
light are we doing any better with light
well these are this is what you see for
light out there you see what waves and
particles
what are waves well they're a bunch of
vectors that are moving very scary stuff
you have these vectors which are
magnitude and direction and they're
shown as moving through space
okay so all we have is a number
that apparently is pointing i don't know
how numbers point but this is what
they're saying that we have values that
are pointing in some direction and these
values are pointing are moving sideways
absolutely scary stuff
and then particles well we cannot
explain with particles why uh
light has
wave properties for example why that
particle is supposed to go up and down
and if it goes up and down what takes it
up what brings it down
so you know we don't we can't
mimic we cannot simulate
light with particles or with waves
both are dead in the water and so what
they did was you know uh essentially
they said um
you know we're going to build the uh
the new
the new model which is the
wave packet
okay what is that well they try to blend
the wave with a particle
and so they said travels as a wave and
arrives and departs as a particle and
that's more or less the description they
have for the wave packet and that's what
they use
can you illustrate a wave packet for me
absolutely not
roger penrose in his book one of his
books he put a corkscrew
and that's a professional mathematician
we just won a nobel prize okay yeah
so science is not an ongoing process
at all
we just have to
answer these questions that's what a
physicist has to answer simply required
to explain mechanisms specifically
action at a distance you know uh you
have um
get this out of here
you have two bowls
here you have two balls
this is all you have to explain okay
this is the only issue remaining and
then we can all become extinct
because we have no more to investigate
in physics physics with this goes
at a dead end it's the end of physics
and that is
two particles you don't like particles
you like planets
two planets
or the earth and the moon or the sun and
the earth or whatever you want doesn't
matter
all you have to explain is action at a
distance
okay so
in magnets as well if you say this is
one magnet this is another magnet
how does this one affect that one
that's all you gotta explain that's the
only issue remaining the only issue that
no one has been able to explain 2 500
years
once we explain that the mechanism we're
done with physics forever there is no
more physics after that
okay so let me repeat that
two planets two particles two magnets
any any one that you want to select i
don't care
you have to explain okay this is it this
is a million dollar question worth two
beers okay
how does this one affect this one
without any mediator
okay
and if you don't put a media here you're
using black magic
therefore you had better put a mediator
make it visible for us just so that we
can understand the mechanism
doesn't mean we're going to believe in
your theory
but you better put some kind of mediator
from here to there otherwise you're
doing black matching so if you're going
to do entanglement and you're going to
say that this particle instantly affects
this one you know like rotating in the
same direction one rotates opposite
direction i'm sorry one rotating
clockwise the other one rotating
counterclockwise
this one affects this one
instantaneously
irrespective of distance
then you one here one atom here the
other one on in the andromeda galaxy 2.5
million light years away that's a
measure of distance
okay traveling at the speed of light two
and a half million
years that's what it would take to get
to andromeda and these people are saying
that when this one moves clockwise this
one moves automatically
counterclockwise
and there's nothing in between them
and here you have the one planet and
another planet and it turns out the moon
or
for example the moon and the earth right
and
the moon affects the tides of earth and
the earth affects
the uh the moon because it's not allowed
to leave the solar system
how does it do it instantaneously how
does it do it at all i mean anyway you
want to explain it but hopefully there's
something that extends
from the earth to the moon from the moon
to the earth
and magnets the same thing you have
magnet attracting magnet hopefully you
put some physical object in between
there otherwise you're doing black magic
okay so that's the whole issue with uh
science and with physics
if you cannot explain that you have not
explained
physics and
that's one of the issues that the
mathematic the only issue really
ultimately that the mathematicians
cannot explain have never explained and
will never explain
if if they
attempt to do it through equations
and they can run all the experiments
they want they're never going to figure
out what invisible intangible entity
mediates
the
transactions and i don't know if i got
through to you with all that but that's
what you gotta that's what you gotta
solve otherwise you don't get the two
beers okay
okay
um
what else do we have here
yeah this is just a punch line on that
or the ending you know i say that you
know you have to tell
this this follow who believes in all
this stuff he thinks we're doing fine
with science
we have to define science and we cannot
use you know what what we've had in the
past because none of those definitions
give us answers to these questions they
cannot tell us anything about gravity
they cannot tell us anything about
magnetism light
electricity the workings of the atom or
even the structure of the atom
none of these
definitions that we have today of
science
you know from the 17th century that's
what we inherited
specifically
experiments right and math obviously but
math already came from the greeks what
was new was experiments
and if you have an intangible invisible
entity what experiment are you going to
run in the lab to detect it to elucidate
you know its
architectural or structural nature
there is none you're just wasting your
time so you we have to define
redefine actually science you know
rational explanations that's what
science is what is physics rational
explanations of uh causes underlying uh
mechanism i spelled underlying in
reverse
i hope you catch that okay math cannot
help decipher
you know causes a mechanism you can't do
it with math and
math is just exclusively descriptions
that's all that math is good for math is
a language that can only describe it has
no power no authority
no wherewithal to
explain okay a mechanism
experiments also cannot disclose
invisible intangible mediators
so it there's no purpose for you going
to the lab and say i'm going to run an
experiment i'm going to verify with an
experiment what are you going to verify
with an experiment here's the experiment
the only experiment you ever needed we
let go of the pencil
watch it's very dangerous very expensive
okay you let go of the pencil and it
falls down
now all you have to do is explain why
the cause the mechanism
what good is an equation what good is
running another experiment you want me
to do it again another experiment okay
let's do it again
and
that's the only experiment you ever
needed for gravity
so no you're not going to
elucidate the invisible intangible
entity by running experiments or doing
math that's why math and
experiments are not part of the
scientific method
okay
because they've never helped us in the
last 400 years
and therefore neither matthew
experiments aren't part of the
scientific method as it relates to
physics okay causes and mechanisms once
we figure out
action at a distance discover the
invisible intangible meteors we are done
with physics we're through
we're finished we're done there's no
more physics after that because now we
understand how the universe works the
only part we cannot explain is actually
an action and distance
people in general can understand you
know one object hitting another one this
we can understand
push
you know more or less we don't know how
this guy moved over there but we don't
care we can understand push because
that's more or less
uh
self-explanatory you visualize say okay
surface to surface this one push that
one we understand push
what no one understands is pull because
for pull you need to put in mediator
okay
and if you don't put a mediator you're
doing black magic that's how simple it
is
okay so a fellow criticizes uh put a
comment on that to me or
thereabouts he says you've got to be
kidding some of the greatest
breakthroughs in science we got thanks
to math enough said
yeah
matt cannot answer those questions so
this fall hasn't uh you know
been around long enough that's that's
the only problem he just uh paris the
establishment he doesn't understand what
the issues are no math cannot tell us
anything about the the cause of gravity
the mechanism of gravity the invisible
mediator of gravity for that you cannot
use any math whatsoever you just gotta
look back think you know and
visualize that's the only way okay and
so this is what we say is there a
rational way to do science
i presented this the other day yeah
there is uh you have to propose the
right approach okay
and
you must ask what is it that the
scientific method is attempting to
achieve what is its purpose you know in
in the context of physics and the answer
cannot rely on tradition democracy you
know voting for
[Music]
you know uh
definition
or um
what's the other authority
you cannot rely on that you cannot say
well we've always done it this way and
this is what my teacher told me and
no none of that you have to
define it in a way that you can defend
your definition of science as it relates
to physics okay so this is not a matter
of opinion it's a matter of can you
defend your theory okay
and yeah we're saying that um
science to this state what we've been
doing for the last 400 years especially
what we've been doing the last 150 years
uh
is completely irrational the
explanations are all all completely
irrational not one of them survives
rationality why because why are they
irrational because they are in the
process they're in the habit or in the
practice of moving concepts around
they explain everything with concepts
they introduce a concept such as energy
or field or wave or
plasma or any of those which are
abstract concepts
and it takes a mathematician to
understand the
two years at least to understand why
those are concepts and not physical
objects okay
i know i didn't miss
miss any word i i didn't put one in
there by mistake you know none of those
are objects time is not an object ether
is not an object
energy is not an object
uh field
force
none of those words charge you know none
of those words that the mathematicians
use
qualify as objects in physics so you
cannot do physics you cannot do physical
interpretations with those concept
abstract mathematical concepts which is
what the mathematicians do
okay so
now you know what the issue is
okay so let's move on to space what the
hell is space what is this thing you
call space
and the first thing you have to
understand is that
this is not a trivial issue in fact the
other day i covered time
and
in comparison space
time is a piece of cake it's easy
i mean it was hard right for all these
people they never defined time but space
space has caused murder
in uh mathematical physics they have no
idea to this day
what space is
so we have to go very slowly
and one of the problems with space is
that whenever people give an explanation
of what
space is for the purposes of
mathematical physics again
oh man
they confuse it with
distance with location
with position with place
they have all these
confused they start using you know they
immediately jump from one subject to
another without telling you what space
is and they start analyzing position and
distance distance traveled
location
they start in
other subjects that have nothing to do
specifically with space they never
define space and they're already moving
on to other subjects and that has
happened throughout history
here are the famous words with which
they
confuse space or which they introduce
whenever they try to explain something
about space specifically what space is
or a definition of space these are the
words are always introduced in there
which have really
nothing to do with the subject at hand
they have nothing to do with telling you
what space is okay here they are okay
become the fundamental concepts that
have stopped and baffled the
mathematicians throughout the ages
and again space is one of those words
that's confused with position which
they've
everyone from the greeks all the way to
newton called place
okay and they kind of
i think newton was the first one to try
to separate place from position okay
i don't know if aristotle did that as
well but
uh point what is a point well it's a
location what is a location it's a
dot that you put to represent the
position and blah blah blah blah blah so
it's
and again a point is one of the
components of a line
what is a line is it a stick now it's a
bunch of locations meaning an itinerary
and so on and so forth so
again they they bring these words to try
to explain space in the context of
trying to elucidate what space is
distant distance traveled and then
distance traveled you have you know the
qualitative notion and the quantitative
notion you know displacement
uh
that's a quantitative notion of distance
traveled okay this will travel i mean
you can travel a certain distance that
doesn't mean you're going to measure and
say this is so many meters that you
travel you can just say there was this
much separation between your starting
point and your ending point and you have
no number you just say that's separation
okay so distance traveled could be
from a qualitative point of view it
could be just distance it could also be
displacement so we separate that as a
distinct concept
line what is a line motion that's what
it is
you know the line they put these dots
they put the stick
and what is that that's just to
represent the one-dimensional what
itinerary like if an itinerary has
dimensions what is it length
uh width height what is and what what i
mentioned does an itinerary have a
trajectory
and
yeah again length dimension exist
they talk about whether space exists or
not
why do they do that well very simple
because they never define the word exist
does god exist
well yes some people say and others say
no and others say maybe
and none of them ever defined the word
exist so we don't know what they're
talking about and they don't know what
they're talking about they go around in
circles they're known as atheist theists
and agnostics all three of them go in
circles because they never defined the
word exist
and yeah you have uh
incessant discussions in circles when
you don't define words key words that
make or break your arguments
object what is an object well it's a
thing it's a figure so is space and
object is it a thing
and man that already
uh
if you look at history especially the
greeks
it's just mind-boggling they just went
around in circles on both object and
exist
and then they never defined the word
concept and so the question is whether
space is a concept is is an object a
concept like some people say
you know
uh yeah
so keep
in mind all these words because we're
gonna go through them right now in one
way or another and uh so that's gonna
give you an idea uh what the problem is
why they've never been able to define
space per se
and here you have it um
in mathematics right uh what they've
done throughout these years is consider
space to be a physical object
they never distinguish between space and
objects space and things okay
they talk about space being 3d
meaning that it has dimensions
um they also equated it with the ether
and
the ether was essentially a bunch of
particles according to the greeks
this region between efficiency in the
case of aristotle but there were
different notions but in his idea it was
uh this substance this thing that
existed between the moon and the uh
earth out there you know especially
above the fire zone that
circumvented the earth
and so this ether was a again a stands
for air so it's a different kind of air
it's like the air that the gods breathe
and of course they imagined as being
made of particles and so that's what the
ether was a bunch of particles that were
out there outside the reach of human uh
understanding okay
and then there's also this notion that
space is a container where all these
particles are in okay so you have the
ether being equal to space and then you
have also the ether
um
the space being the container of ether
like if it's a container a bunch of
particle a bunch of marbles or you know
a
sand uh
beach or you know whatever
sandbox okay just a bunch of grains that
are somehow trapped within space and the
issue there again is what separates one
grain from another what are you going to
call that
and yeah that's called space in that
case and you still haven't answered what
space is
space has been equated to a field which
is also considered to be a thing by the
mathematicians why because they vibrate
them
they say that space moves in other words
this field moves vibrate and that is
what space is a field that's vibrating
it's also a particle so space is
particles space is also equal to energy
they say that you have all these
particles uh energetic particles coming
in from the void and it's just pure
energy that goes back to being energy
when when the particles recombine
okay so space has always been considered
to be a thing
they use adjectives such as finite and
infinite which are only applicable to
objects and these are the ones that they
use to qualify space is space finite is
there a border is it uh
does it have a surface if so what's on
the outside of it and if it's infinite
well is it a thing because all objects
are finite and so what is space if space
is infinite what kind of object is it
what kind of thing is it
and that's why we need to define these
words what a thing is what uh what a
concept is and so on
okay uh then they say that there
could be parallel universes and this is
really surrealistic because they
separate these
universes always in pictures using some
black stuff
and they insinuate that black stuff is
space
which is actually what's contained
within each universe so you have a
universe that has space time and matter
within it but all these universes are
separated by space
yeah sure makes a lot of sense
and uh then they say space was created
the big bang like it was a thing that
was created and yeah you can imagine
poor old god you know uh trying to
create space hopefully he was successful
because until then he had no shape he
had nothing to give him
contour
so hopefully
god was quick at creating space that's
my
my sincere wish for him okay okay so um
what are you go we go to these people
well we go back to the days of the
greeks because they essentially debated
all the issues that we still have today
so if you go to the age of the greeks
you know philosophers as they're known
um
you get an idea of what we have not made
any progress on in the last 2 500 years
we have the same exact questions today
and the same debates and the same
arguments and it looks like people don't
read greek
history or at least the philosophers and
that's why they repeat the same
arguments because if they went back and
they read what the greeks wrote and what
they talked about they would find out
that those same subjects are alive and
well today we have not progressed a
single yoda in
two thousand five hundred years
okay so here it goes uh this is mr
parmenides and uh he wasn't the first
obviously he he just made a couple
arguments that are interesting to start
our conversation today with okay here it
is and he is quoted here because we lost
a lot of material that belonged to
permanentes but here is uh one fellow
his name was uh
ashes
and he said this is how he quotes
parmenides or summarizes you know
parmenides cosmology okay the air has
been separated off from the earth
vaporized by its more violent
condensation and the sun in the circle
of the milky way are excel
exhalations of fire okay so they thought
there you see these that fire there and
you see uh the earth uh
surrounded by water surrounded by air
and surrounded by fire and the black
stuff there that was the ether yeah that
was outside our reach a bunch of
particles that
somehow filled that gap between uh the
moon and us the moon is a mixture of uh
both earth and fire okay the ether lies
around above all else and beneath it is
ranged the fury part the the fire there
right
uh which we call heaven beneath which
are the regions around the earth
this was the notion that parmenides had
uh of cosmology
and this is how we end up with his
notion of space okay he says really
there is no such thing as space because
if there were
then we'd be in a lot of trouble because
would be mean that space is a thing
okay and listen to his argument
he says assume uh let me remove this
here
it says
assume
this is a train of thought okay assume
there exists a void
meaning space nothing okay
void is equal to nothing right but
nothing
cannot exist
something can exist but nothing what do
you mean nothing exists no nothing
cannot exist therefore there is no such
thing as
void as nothing
because if
if there is something called void you're
essentially turning it into a thing so
to speak
and if it's a thing
then it exists
and but nothing does not exist and if
nothing does not exist then there is no
such thing as void
that was his line of reasoning and so he
or lack of you could
so he was under the notion that there is
no such thing as change there's no such
thing as motion
because
he he concluded that something cannot
move into
a void because there is no such thing as
a void
okay
because if there were something
as a void it would exist and if it
exists then it's not avoid because the
void is nothing and nothing does not
exist
and that was his train of thought
and indeed he says uh there's always
something there there's air there's
water there's light
there's always something in that region
you think has a void in it there's
something there
okay
so anyways this was his uh train of
thought okay his way of thinking
and he was opposed by the atomos like
democratus and lucipus who uh were in
abdurah
uh and phrase okay
and they didn't pay too much attention
these guys they really brushed them
aside says motion requires a void in
other words you cannot conceive a motion
without a void somehow you know things
have to move into somewhere
and he says observation proves that
there is motion therefore there must be
a void
and so this is how their argument for
brushing uh permanentes and his
disciples aside he's saying you know
there is motion and there had better be
a void because you have to be able to
move into
you know one of these voids in order for
there to be motion
and so these were the arguments that
they raised and we'll see that they're
still alive and well even today you know
people still debate these things
okay so uh a century later you have
aristotle come in and he puts his grain
of sand he puts his peace of mind in
there okay
and i'm not going to go to plato and
some of the others that also discuss
this issue okay just trying to hop so
that you get the big picture here
and sir aristotle says the investigation
of similar questions about the void also
must be held to belong to the physicist
now there's a physicist has to look at
this issue it's a subject matter of
physics namely whether it exists or not
does the void exist or not this was one
of the issues that kept the greek
so-called philosophers up at night okay
and how it exists or what it is
so they were trying to figure out what
the void is does it exist okay
and if it exists you know again what are
you talking about what is this thing you
call void or space okay
and the problem is that uh
aristotle especially even people who
came after
they started confusing or discussing
space in terms of
place the word they used was place or it
was translated as place
if you look at it it's
as far as i'm concerned it's the
position of mathematics today the word
position essentially replace the word
place
newton says one as we're going to see in
a minute that
position is just qualitative well place
is quantitative that's the way he looked
at it
but what is place place is the
volume occupied by an object that's the
notion all these people had
and so they started talking about
whether an object occupies
a
volume
and what is the volume it's the object
itself
because it turns out the volume happens
to meet the same shape as the object
okay so this was their notion
what this has to do with space like
you know in the universe you know the
space out there the black stuff
i don't know but they they they
their reasoning all had to do with local
stuff
they said if if i take a ball and i move
it from here to there like i move it in
water well we can see how it displaces
water
okay so now i move it to air
does it displace air they said they
concluded yeah this place is air because
the air moves somewhere else and now
that object occupies that volume of air
that air occupied before
and from that they started trying to
figure out whether there was a void
what was it that the ball occupied
and whether before it occupied that it
was filled
and whether it was filled or not
can you say that the void exists that
that place
that location or that
position
that volume doesn't exist on its own
before the ball occupies it
those were the issues
and with that reasoning they were trying
to figure out what space is out there
the universal space you know
which
in the case of newton he's going to call
he's got to refer to that as absolute
space and he's going to refer to this
stuff over here really the way i look at
it okay as the relative space
and that's also what einstein's going to
later on take over he's going to say oh
relative
relativity you know rings a bell
okay so he says those who hold that the
void exists regard it as a sort of place
or vessel which is supposed to be uh
full
when it holds the bulk which it is
capable of containing so it's full when
it's got the
thing that occupies that volume okay
that's what he's saying void when it is
deprived of that now it's a void okay so
if you deprive it of that thing that you
put in that volume now you have void
deprived of the object that occupy the
void in other words now you're saying is
there such a thing as a standalone void
before anything occupies it that was the
issue okay
as a void and full in place denoted the
same thing
as if they were all synonyms
and again he's saying is the void the
same thing as the volume
and is there such a thing as a volume
without something occupying that volume
and that was the issue
those who try to show that the void does
not exist do not disprove what people
really mean by it but only
their erroneous way of speaking in other
words he thought they were just playing
semantics when they played all these
little tricks and he says he's going to
clarify for you
you know what really is this void thing
and whether it exists or not okay
he was on top of things okay and so here
he goes he says the void is thought to
be
place with nothing in it okay clear
the volume
the reason for this is that
and here it's interesting that he's got
the definition of exist almost at his
fingertips okay people take what exists
to be body and hold that while everybody
is in place
okay
so he's saying that what is exists
it's body
that has
place which is not totally correct
that's position that's volume but if you
look at it he was very close to saying
body that has location
so interesting and they would have
missed it anyways okay
void is a place in which there is no
body okay so that where there is nobody
there must be void okay
everybody again they are supposed to be
tangible so he's thinking that body is
that which you can touch
otherwise it's not a body
in other words again they had the
c-touch notion and not the notion of
shape which is how euclid is going to
define figure saying
you know it's that which has a boundary
uh what is it
definition 14 in his first book
and then you say okay what is a boundary
and that you go to back to definition 13
and says boundary is the cover
of a figure so we have a circular set of
definitions figures that which has
boundary boundary is that which is the
outside of a figure great we learned a
lot but uh
that would have been correct for
or close enough for what an object is
but here he's saying no that's that
which you can touch
okay so again they had no idea what an
object is first of all and second you
know they never discovered how important
defining the word object is for physics
okay
and they never used these definitions
anyways okay they just casually use the
c-touch uh definition okay so that's big
problem right there
and uh so he says so that where there is
no body there must be void okay
everybody again they supposed to be
tangible and again that's not the
definition of body and of this nature is
whatever has weight or lightness again
he's saying that anything that has
weight
mass today i guess
whether it's heavier light
he says that's also a quality or a
property of objects
and hence by syllogism what we have
nothing what has nothing heavy or light
in it is void
so void has no uh shape no you can't
touch it it's got no weight etc etc etc
okay um so what is the problem here okay
uh he continues says void must if it
exists okay he's talking about the
existence of void be placed deprived of
body we have stated both in what sense
place exists and in what sense it does
not it is plain that on this showing
void does not exist either unseparated
or separated the void is meant to be not
body but rather an interval in body in
other words void is what separates a
body that's what he's saying okay it's
what creates a discontinuity
this is why the void is thought to be
something okay so uh
again the problem with his whole
reasoning is that he's not really
addressing what space is out there he's
just looking at position
which he calls place
and he's saying
places void
a chunk
of space he's talking about that little
chunk he's talking about the volume
where he's going to put
a thing in there okay and he says if we
take the thing out is do we still have
the volume there stand alone volume with
nothing in it
and again that has nothing to do with
world with space because it cannot even
be conceived
i mean what sense does it take does it
make to talk about a volume of space
within space
this is where they got caught this is
where they made their air because if if
space is this whole thing you got to
talk about space and not tell me about
what happens at the microscopic level
here on earth compared to space out
there right
talking about volume being occupied by
an object and without the object you
have a volume of space
in space
yes uh the volume of water in water
what's a volume of air and air what is
that
you're gonna kind of um
encapsulate it
with what how do you separate space from
space how do you spec separate void
place volume
from infinite space right i mean if if
that's what space is infinite you know
an infinite object or whatever
so this is where the where the um
irrationality uh stepped in okay they
never figure that out
okay so what does good old newton say
okay he comes in a few centuries later
and again we're going to skip day card
and some of the other guys in between
uh
he starts in his skull he says this
right up front he says i do not define
time space place
and motion as being well known to all
now what a way to start his book that's
at the beginning of his book so he's not
going to tell you what space or place is
and then he does he gives it a the best
shot he can and what he does is separate
absolute from relative space
whatever that means i mean i thought
space was space with space and now he's
going to separate him why because he's
going to be doing numbers on them he's
going to talk about uh distance traveled
he's going to talk about location
actually position which is
in mathematics it's mathematics really
because it's mathematical physics uh
they're all synonyms you know
motion and position and displacement all
three of them are synonyms
they don't use the word motion they use
the word displacement why because it's a
number placed on motion
and what is position the same thing
exactly the same thing position is
motion it's how many
uh miles how many meters whatever you
move from a to b they want to know an
amount which is what they're going to be
putting in an equation what is the
position well it's so many meters here
and so many meters there
what does it mean distance traveled so
there's no difference between distance
traveled motion displacement and
position
in mathematics
in mathematical physics only i must
observe that the vulgar uh conceive
uh those quantities
under an uh other
and no other notions uh but from the
relations they bear uh
to sensible objects again touch
okay so that he's he's comparing that to
sensible objects okay and then it's a
rise certain prejudices for the removing
of which it will be convenient to
distinguish them into absolute and
relative true and apparent mathematical
and common okay he's got to separate
these things um
in mathematics essentially okay
and so here uh
he continues
this one there hold on
put it up here
uh so he he defines pain a place here
okay to show you that it's not the same
thing as position which i think they are
but he thought they weren't and he said
place is a part of space which a body
takes up and is according to the space
either absolute or relative okay so he's
he's trying to separate this word place
from position essentially i say a part
of space not the situation nor the
external surface of the body
for the places
of equal solids are always equal but
they're
super faces by reason of their
dissimilar figures are often unequal so
he's saying that you know he's he's got
to compare here uh position against
place essentially positions properly
have no quantity nor are they so much
the places themselves as the properties
of places
okay so uh
i i think he just complicated things
because he's trying to create a
numerical space and differentiate that
from uh
qualitative uh space
and of course uh it doesn't stop with
newton when you work your way forward
you get to einstein he's going to pick
up more or less on the same notion but
he's going to go more with the
aristotelian notion and this is what
einstein has to say okay this is his
notion of space which we all know quite
well today and this is from nasa so it's
official okay einstein thought space and
time were intertwined in an infinite
fabric like an
outstretched blanket
canvas fishnet
okay
uh fabric
domestic art massive objects such as the
sun bends the space-time blanket with it
with its gravity
okay we've all seen the picture i've
shown it several times here it goes one
more time okay there it is that's what
einstein had in mind he's saying there's
a blanket there's a
canvas fishnet whatever you want to call
that fabric okay and the sun weighs it
down
and the earth cannot escape
the solar system because there's a wall
of time curveball time i don't know if
you see it there there's the moon also
going right through the wall okay why
because the moon circles the earth but
the earth is weighing down
its own canvas
but the
canvas of the of the sun
encapsulates the earth
because the earth is rolling around that
canvas and because it's way down it also
throws the moon around itself and so we
have a problem where the
moon somehow goes through the wall of
time that the sun creates for the earth
okay so this is a contradiction so
realistic
okay and here you have the big picture
this is the official picture okay again
we have there the earth
moving the moon around itself this is
the notion that they have this is the
explanation the physical interpretation
they have for
gravity
why the moon doesn't leave the solar
system okay
sorry
give me a second here
okay so uh
this is a fella who asked a question i'm
gonna
look at that later on
anyways what we have from einstein is
the
is the uh
canvas
version of space
and it's somehow blended it with time
it's warped and that's what prevents the
earth from flying out of the solar
system these are the explorations we
have today so what is space well space
is some kind of fabric
it's a thing
so we have all kinds of things and space
is also a thing
there is no such thing as nothing
and that's a little
uh
counter-intuitive you know there's no
such thing as a as a nothing
and we kind of agree with that yeah
there is no such thing as nothing
because nothing is a no
thing
and so the question is
there is no such
notion as nothing as void as vacuum
in mathematics that's the issue so
today we've ended up in many ways
like they ended up with like the week
greeks started you know 2 500 years ago
they started debating what is space and
they said there's no such thing as space
because if if space is a thing then it
would exist
okay and so it's really nothing but then
what is that volume that an object
occupies well that's a thing
okay so there is no such thing as no
thing
okay as a
empty volume up there out there it's
always a volume that is a thing in
itself because there's always something
in it
and so there's no such thing as nothing
no such notion as nothing and the
relativists have ended up with the same
notion they said today there's no such
notion as nothing
in in all of mathematical physics
okay so
we ended up where we started at least
the mathematicians ended up where we
started
okay so here we have um
this uh
notion of uh the definition of space
today and it is that space the boundless
three-dimensional extent blah blah blah
blah blah blah continues
it's an extent that's what the wikipedia
tells us so what is an extent well you
look it up and says the space or degree
to which a thing extends length area
volume so that's great and extent is an
extend of what uh of space
and i thought space was the extent so an
extended space okay great okay we
learned a lot
and there's another definition that's in
the dictionary.com space the unlimited
or incalculably great three-dimensional
expanse
what's an expanse an uninterrupted space
or area wide extent of anything so we're
back to the
synonyms
uh spaces in expanse which in which is
an extent which is a space
great
what have we learned
not much believe me okay
and so what do we have
here ah keep putting this thing in there
i'll get this later on
what they have we have mr robert lofland
and he's a um
what is it he's a
nobel prize winner
and here we have it this is what he says
the modern concept of vacuum of space
means space right
confirmed every day by experiment is a
relativistic ether but we do not call it
this because it is taboo
so after 2 500 years yes confirmed space
is ether
space is where we started off we haven't
changed one single
yoda we haven't changed a single bit in
our notion of space mathematical physics
i mean okay so what have we learned well
nothing really we haven't learned much
uh from the mathematical physicist
in
2500 years because now we have
the same space the ether the
thing the object
that the greek started out with or
debated from the start
what do we call space under
science here it is okay here's the
definition
definition of science we have object
that which has shape
space that which doesn't have shape
see how easy it was
hopefully nothing and something are
antonyms and there you have it in those
two definitions
nothing is uh that which has no shape
and something is that which has shape
and yeah one is an antonym of the other
and so we have solved the riddle finally
you know what space is
it's nothing what is nothing that which
has no shape which is an antonym of
something which is that which has shape
see how easy it was all along can you
talk about the existence of space of
nothing
absolutely not because exist and we'll
get to that later on but exists is an
object that has location
it has to be an object it has to be a
thing it has to be some thing
nothing is not something nothing is the
opposite it's an antonym of something
and you need a something to have
existence so you cannot talk about the
existence of nothing
we're done
i hope you didn't miss it otherwise
review
okay
okay let's get on with uh
some of the questions people ask
kept putting this other one in there i
don't know how it got in there
okay give me a second here let me
arrange them okay here's a first issue
of fellow ass he says
could there be things other than
objects in the universe that we can only
describe in terms like fields because we
are fundamentally unable to understand
them in other ways
he says he thinks a field is a thing
or
if a field is a concept he says can't we
try to understand him in terms of fields
or for he just gave that as an example
as a concept because we can probably
understand it as a concept not as an
object
and that's why we have to distinguish
between objects and concepts okay we
need to differentiate these two terms
and here it is concepts we define and
understand
concept a word that invokes or embodies
two objects what is an object
well we point to it and visualize it
because it is that which has shape
so a concept is a word that is founded
on the word object you must first define
the word object before you define the
word
concept objects we point to and
visualize and concepts we define and
understand so when when you get once you
get the definitions right
then
you you have an easier time
understanding why we cannot replace one
with the other we cannot
give you
uh physical interpretations especially
using concepts we cannot use the word
field or the word energy or the word uh
force
charge
wave any of those words you can't use
any of those words to do physical
interpretations because they're concepts
you're introducing a concept as a
physical object to make your case that's
the problem and that's what the
mathematicians have been doing now for
at least 400 years
certainly in the last 150 years
okay uh phil says a thing is that which
has shape which i said that okay and he
says a question begging definition with
regards to spatial extent that avoids
the issue of whether any objects
actually even have strict boundaries to
begin with
so he gives the example of uh cloud
we can even give a better example and
that's the example of gas
you have i mean air what is the shape of
air he might say okay he says where does
it stop
well first of all so you know he says
where does it begin how do you know
where it stops and
uh how can you define that exactly if
you're going to talk about uh an object
that which has shaped there are things
like clouds and
gases and
water maybe i don't know what other
examples you might have in mind where
you cannot tell where the thing stops
and what you say what is the shape of
that
and so the first issue is that yes we
can define exactly okay
um
a blob of gas and say where the last
atom ends
that's where the shape ends
that's one issue
okay we take a cross section
of time
we take a single snapshot because some
people say well but it keeps changing
it's a cross-section of time okay one
frame in the universal film it's a
snapshot you're not looking at a movie
you're looking at a single picture so
when you're talking about air you're now
looking at oh well air moves around and
water moves around now
you take a snapshot of air you take a
snapshot of
water you color code the air because you
can't see it so you color code it take a
snapshot and say that's air that blob of
gas that's air
what does the air look like around the
earth it looks like a sphere
and it ends where the last atom ends
ends and you can take it as far as you
want that in that air what is the issue
what is the problem that this individual
has
the problem is that he's asking the
wrong question
okay he doesn't understand
what question he's got to ask
the question is not what is the shape of
gas what is the shape of a cloud where
does the last atom end
the
issue is
does
gas
have shape does a cloud have shape
does water have shape
and you had better say yes
to that question to all those questions
if you put water in a bottle
you can see the shape in there
you say oh but that's because the glass
it takes the shape of the glass we don't
care
we don't care in fact we can take water
in a balloon
ask the astronaut to take it out there
into space okay so we have water inside
a balloon
and it's a
space resistance
he pops the balloon
he pops the balloon this blob of water
comes on
or color-coded air if you want whatever
you take a snapshot of
that does that blob
of water does that blob over here have
shape it's a yes or no question
and you had better say yes that it does
have shape
otherwise maybe you're blind or you have
some problem mental problems okay so
yeah water and air do have shape because
they're made out of atoms anything that
is made out of atoms had better have
shape i don't care if it takes the shape
of the
container or not irrelevant
does it have shape we don't ask what is
the shape of energy what is the shape of
mass we say does mass have shape does
energy have shape
and the answer had better be no
energy is a concept concepts don't have
shape so is mass
okay if it says s
talking about the chiseled out black
parts between objects as nothingness
okay because i said uh you take an
object okay and you put it within space
and so the question is
uh he says if it were nothing then it
wouldn't exist again i'm talking about
they're mixing object with exists this
is where where the problem really starts
right and therefore there wouldn't be
any blackness between the objects in
question
he's saying if we have nothing between
the cube and the sphere
then they should be touching
there should be
one thing
uh continuous object there should be two
things
they should be touching at least okay
because uh if you've got nothing between
them that's what he's saying okay
there would be space between things if
space were nothingness
okay
there is nothing between them means they
are touching by any intuitive
interpretation of the words being and
here
uh use here um
the problem this spell has is
again it happens with all these
religious folks that or the people who
think they're philosophers or whatever
they are
they have no idea how to ask questions
and they never visualize any of this
stuff and above all they never defined
the words that they're going to use in
their dissertation that's the whole
problem no definition
so nothing is not a synonym of distance
because you say if there's nothing
between the cube and the ball they're
touching
and turns out there is nothing between
the cube and the ball
it's that black stuff there that's
nothing it has no shape i had to give it
a little bit of shape there to make my
case but it has no shape
that's what space is it has no shape and
there is distance between them they're
not touching even though there's nothing
between them
even though there's nothing between them
i don't know if that's
okay
so um
you know
he's got
it all screwed up in his mind
he says he continues as you point out a
response to this blackness being a thing
in that there must be a meta space for
this space to be
in followed by a meta meta space now
there was space within space and there
was a picture i was showing earlier by
mistake but here it is hopefully this is
the right one
ah
what happened to this
give me a second here
a problem with that one all day long
today
okay here it is
here's an object uh and uh we say that
it has shape that's that white thing in
the center
what's the black stuff the black stuff
is space
if you're gonna say that space is an
object if you're gonna treat space as an
object
you it had better have shape meaning it
has better be contoured by something
else
okay so now you got to identify the
white stuff on the outside of the black
stuff
that's the issue so he's saying this
sort of response is something actually
brought up by some of these medieval
minds and it falls prey to the kind of
argument that is if my legs move me and
legs are required for movement then
those legs must also have legs of their
own to move
ad nauseum and
turtles all the way down you pref you
brief face
that we need to stop somewhere and if
anything we
not just define an entity as that being
which stops the bug okay
uh why not why not stop you know why not
just definitely is that which stops the
bug well no we we have a serious problem
here because uh once again
you know the issue is that we don't have
a definition of the word uh motion
as that which is carried by legs the
definition of motion is here okay
here you have distance separation
between objects
location is the set of distances okay
and motion is two or more locations
where do you see legs defining you know
the word motion
okay so
it's not the same it's not a good
analogy but this fellow arrays are
saying look if uh
if you say that we need a
container for space because
we're turning space into an object
instead of just stopping there
uh well i can say the same thing he says
about uh
motion because he says that you need two
legs to move and then if that that would
raise the question is do i need two legs
to move the two legs and so on down line
well that's a poor
uh analogy because again we don't define
motion as that which requires two legs
we re
define motion as two or more locations
and if we do that you know
then um
you know you can't say that you need too
late that it's a good analogy for what
i'm doing with space
we're defining an object is that which
has shape
okay
and an object has to be contoured by
something and ultimately for all objects
it's space
space cannot be an object itself because
then
if space is an object now by definition
of the word object you need something to
contour space that's just applying the
definition
you can't say that the leg analogy is a
good analogy for what i just said
because the definition of the word
motion
is not that which needs two legs which
also needs two legs which also needs two
legs which is an infinite regress no
we're saying moshe's two or more
locations
for a particular type of motion say you
need two legs
but then you can't say then you need two
legs to move those two legs because
that's not the definition of motion
okay i don't know if that sank in okay
you can't use that as an analogy okay so
again
okay one file says
ropes and threads are also made of
particles
no one can envision a sub uh
substance or object that is indivisible
i think he meant uh divisible
but either way i i don't know uh i'm
saying that there is such an object we
conceptualize it and here it is i'm
going to conceptualize it for you there
it is it's a single thread
it's made out of a single piece
it is flexible despite being made of a
single piece okay
and it's what underlies all
objects in the universe and it's not
made of parts because again it's made of
a single piece and it's flexible despite
being made of a single piece okay that's
the assumption that underlies
the single thread
and so uh yeah we can conceptualize it
there you see it okay it's not made of
parts
okay so i don't know what his problem is
why he can't conceptualize it okay
okay he also seems to have or someone
here seems to have problems with planes
he says three dimensions is the minimum
for any visible object
okay for visible object could be so what
it is impossible to draw or imagine a 3
a 2d object because the pencil graphite
or ink particles on the paper have depth
all objects require depth to be
visible yeah but the definition of
object is not that which you can see
the definition of objects that which has
shape
okay and so um
i don't know what his problem is he says
he can't visualize he can't see a 2d
object no i show him an object that has
shape it's a triangle and
i can see it i don't know maybe he's
blind he can't see it
and he says well it has to have depth
well that one doesn't have depth but the
one on the
right over there the one on the lower
right that one has depth it's a pyramid
and we're seeing one face of it only
and we call it a triangle
and so i don't know what his problem is
yeah it could have depth and maybe not
we don't care
it has nothing to do with devs and has
nothing to do with seeing it has to do
with does it have shape and hopefully
that triangle and that pyramid both of
them have shape
so yeah
an object is that which has shape not
that which you can see or touch and
that's where this fellow gets confused
okay here's another fellow and he says
i don't see why science needs to change
because i'm saying we need a new
definition of science as i discussed
today there's nothing stopping you from
trying to explain things via
non-scientific methods
philosophers do that all the time
well uh the so-called philosophers are
not philosophers uh there haven't been
philosophers any time since the days of
the greeks all the way to i don't know
whitney and scott
wittgenstein ayn rand uh
sartre
none of those were philosophers
what they were is uh religious people
who
gave recommendations they talked about
their beliefs
they
told you how the world should be run
they give you their personal opinions
and that's not a philosopher philosophy
is not
uh a way of thinking
love of knowledge or any of those
definitions
uh philosophy has never been defined
and here's here's a line you go to the
what is the stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy
the only word you won't find defined
uh is the word philosophy
so here's the stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy and they don't define
philosophy so we have no idea what
philosophy means
and we don't know what that encyclopedia
is about then
and yeah that shows
a lot because if everyone is a
philosopher you know because everybody
has a way of thinking and opinion
a love of wisdom
then uh
how do you say that aristotle was a
philosopher a greek philosopher well
there are millions of others uh greek
philosophers everybody's a philosopher
then because if it's just a way of
thinking of opinions of giving
recommendations on how to live
well that's not philosophy
you know that's religion
philosophy is something else and we have
to define what philosophy is
it's
the other branch of science
and we say it's got to do with
explanations because science is
explaining rationally rational
explanations in philosophy you have to
rational explain rationally what do you
have to explain
uh purposes and reasons that's different
than physics which explains causes and
mechanisms
so philosophers are only those who
explain
purposes and reasons and very few if any
have done that in in the history of
philosophy so-called philosophy
okay so uh yeah
he's saying that
doing non-scientific method yeah those
are non-scientific method which is what
mathematical physics does they do
non-scientific methods okay so
we do have to change science because
people think that mathematics you know
mathematical physics is science and
that's where the error comes in it's not
science because they give you a
an irrational physical interpretations
and science is
rational physical interpretations
okay anyways regardless the models
created by the scientific method are
still incredibly useful
even if they don't provide satisfying
answers
to big questions yeah we don't care
about useful because useful has to do
with
uh
technology and technology has nothing at
all to do with science technology
developing gadgets through trial and
error
science
explaining
mechanism in the case of physics
planning causes and mechanisms
building electrical systems without a
model of electromagnetism would be nigh
impossible yeah because again uh
this father thinks that technology is
science science technology or that
technology is proof or evidence of
theories
not the case okay and i've got a video
on that
uh justification enough for science no
absolutely not because science has
nothing to do with technology and this
is where people make air they think that
technology and signs are synonyms
they're not in fact one has nothing to
do with the other at all
okay one file says
oh dear the question of why the moon
rotates around the earth is well
understood is it
okay let's see the answer is gravity
that's why the earth goes around
the moon goes around the earth because
of gravity okay finally we have an
answer okay the attraction between two
bodies okay great so that's
that was the reason the moon doesn't fly
away okay i see now however the reason
for why gravity occurs
is what is the thing that uh
in other words what is the thing that is
causing the attraction is not understood
yeah
it's not understood because you have not
identified the thing
that is causing it
that's why it's not understood
once we identified the thing
thing that which i shape okay once we
identify the thing then we understand
how gravity works and why the moon
doesn't fly away very simple okay
if you're going to
straw man try and be less obvious so you
think that question
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system why the moon doesn't fly
out of um
the earth orbit he thinks those are uh
straw man straw manning
okay uh one more question here
paul says
singularities can have mass
because all the atoms exist at that
point
okay so we have a singularity
zero dimensional but we have all the
atoms at that point okay something
infinitely small has no size
okay
that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
well uh you know i mean why waste my
time even answering all these questions
this guy's not even you know on the
planet
where did he get all these
contradictions
he doesn't even realize that he just
mentions all this stuff he doesn't even
know what he's saying
okay
anyways not not even
worth it to
spend a little bit of breath on any of
those issues
with that i'll see you what is it on
sunday we'll see you there bye-bye